so this night is a very special one who
did you love meeting who did you love
seeing for the first time we're seeing
again oh I just saw bebe Rexha that's
the second time I've met her she is so
sweet and cool normal I love her halsy I
was so excited to see she killed it um
but music awards are always the most fun
because people go all out you know you
can't it's like it's a big party so
they're they're really fun to come to
and so how do you feel stepping out in
the front I mean we just saw you once
you'd be there so bad for the crowd kind
of loves you
Thanks I get nervous I really do nervous
right before JWoww actually we both were
like but it's fun it's always fun to go
to these things yeah when you're with
Jay well are you trading stories about
like reality shows stuff ups and downs
like what are you guys talk about yeah
she was just telling me that they do two
weeks on and then they go home for a
week to see her kids I was like that's
crazy
Ayanna I could never do that yeah so we
were talking about you are different
shooting schedules now and like my
shooting schedule I mean I'm able to
film and then be home for dinner with my
kids and so I feel like I truly have the
best of both worlds living in a house
with everybody and film me for two weeks
without seeing my kids I don't think I
could do it I don't think I could but
yeah and I was asked cuz I've met the
whole Jersey Shore crew so I was asking
all about them and catching up on
everybody as well what I deleted on
another season
how does filming the show like this with
like I mean it's your family life yeah
how does it affect your family life yeah
well my kids aren't on it and so it's
interesting because we tried to film
when we were at my house either while
they're at school my daughter is
sleeping or after they go to bed and we
really limited the time that we would
film at the house just and they were
around it sometimes and they loved
watching the monitor and being part of
it but it's interesting because you know
now it's I have a husband I have three
kids so it's not just me anymore that I
have to look out for I mean when I was
18 19 20 sure it was just me I could do
it over the hell I wanted onto and it
didn't affect anybody with me but now I
have to be very careful and so I'm an
executive producer this time around and
just having that security blanket and
just knowing that if I needed to get
something taken out I could it just um
it's nice it's really nice Billy
approached you about doing veils when
they're in the back yeah they did I
can't right cuz of my show I would love
to and I'm
reading them on I hope the show is a
huge success I'll be watching and I
still talk to everybody so I'm excited
for them it was such a phenomenon when
you were on I mean everybody everybody
watched it everybody got like what they
thought was a peek inside your lives but
now those are there's a different
everybody wants everyone else to have a
peek inside their lives so what have you
seen change in terms of media how people
interact with and what they want from it
yeah well gosh it's so different with
social media now I remember right when
the hill's was ending I wasn't on any
social media or I think I just joined
Twitter but it's it's a different world
I don't know I mean I think everything
now is just so in instant and you know I
think fan for fans I think it's nice
because they can watch an episode and
then they can instantly go on and feel
as though they're talking to you so it's
just I don't know it's a weird
interesting time it just is social media
is sort of a love-hate relationship with
me ultimately I love it but I think it
can also be kind of a dark place as well
so it's just I don't know I think you
just I don't read my comments anymore
cuz I just feel like just for my mental
health I think good or bad it's not
normal or healthy so I just choose not
to how do you find that balance do you
think people should like take regular
breaks from it other rules that you
abide by other than not video comments
um pretty much just don't read comments
and just when I'm with my kids I'm with
my kids I don't want to sit there and
scroll on Instagram and I'm guilty of it
but I find that it's such a waste of
time when I could be focusing on my kids
so I just try to like just do those
little things yeah great I don't know